PROFESSOR: Find
our final solution,
we just have to
match the equations.
So Psi continues at x equals a.
And what do we have?
Well from two, you
have cosine of ka.
And from four you would have
a equals e to the minus ka.
This is the value of this--
so the interior
solution at x equals
a must match the value of
the exterior solution of k
equals a.
Psi prime must be continuous
at x equals a as well.
Well what is the derivative
of this function?
It's minus the sine of this.
So it's minus k sine
of kx, that becomes ka,
is equal to the derivative
of that one, which
is minus Kappa A e to
that minus Kappa little a.
Two equations, and
how many unknowns?
Well there's A and some
information about Kappa and k.
And the easiest way to eliminate
that is to divide them.
So you divide the bottom
equation by this equation.
So what do we get?
Divide the bottom by the top.
Minus k and and
the minuses cancel,
we can cancel those
minus signs and you
get k tan ka is equal to Kappa.
But you already are
convinced, I hope, on the idea
that we should not use
equations that have units.
So I will multiply by
little a and a little a
to get a [INAUDIBLE] size, and
therefore, the right hand side
becomes Xi equals, and the
left side become Eta tan Eta.
OK, I want to make a little
comment about these quantities
already.
So all the problem has turned
out into the following.
You were given a potential and
that determines a number z0.
If you know the width and
everything, you know z0.
Now you have to
calculate Eta and Xi.
If you know either Eta or
Xi, you know Kappa or k.
And if you know either k or
Kappa, since you know v0,
you will know the energy.
So it's kind of neat to
express this more clearly,
and I think it's maybe
easier if one uses Xi.
And look at Xi squared is
Kappa squared times a squared.
And what is Kappa
squared, it's over there.
2m absolute value of e, a
squared over h bar squared.
Now you want to find e, you're
going to get in some units.
Even e is nice to
have it without units.
So I will multiply
and divide by v0.
2m v0 a squared over h squared,
absolute value of e over v0.
After all, you probably
prefer to know e
over v0, which tells you how
proportional the energy is
to the depth of the potential.
And this is your
famous constant z0.
So e over v0 is actually
equal to Xi over z0 squared.
And this is something
just to keep in mind.
If you know Xi, you
certainly must know z0,
because that's not
in your potential,
and then you know how
much is the energy.
All very convenient things.
So punchline for solutions.
So what do we have?
We have two equations.
This equation maybe
should be given a number.
Xi equals 8 at tan Eta and Eta
and Xi squared giving you z
squared.
So how do we solve it?
We solve it graphically.
We have Psi, Eta,
and then we say,
oh, let's try to plot
the two equations.
Well this is a circle.
Eta squared plus Psi squared.
Now Xi and Eta must
be positive, so we
look at solutions
just in this quadrant.
Let's put here pi over 2.
Pi 3 pi over 2, 2 pi, and
here is Eta and there is Xi.
Well this is a circle, as we
said, but let's look at this.
Xi equals Eta tan Eta.
That vanished as Eta goes
to 0 and will diverge
at Eta equals pi over 2.
So this part, at
least, looks like this.
And then it will go
negative, which don't care,
from this region, and
then reach here at pi.
And after pi, it will
go positive again
and it will reach
another infinity here.
And then at 3 pi, at 2 pi,
it will go again and reach
not another infinity like that.
So these are these curves.
And the other curve, the
circle, is just a circle here.
So, for example, I could
have a circle like this.
So the radius of this
circle is radius z0.
And there you go, you've
solved the problem.
At least intuitively
you know the answer.
And there's a lot of things that
come out of this calculation.
If the radius z0 is 3
pi over 2, for example,
and the radius z0 represents
some potential of some depth
and width, there will
be just two solutions.
These are these solutions.
These points represent values
of Xi and values of Eta,
from which you could
read the energy.
In fact, you can look
at that state and say,
that's the state of
largest Xi, and therefore
it's the state of the largest
absolute value of the energy.
It's the most
deeply bound state.
Then this is next
So there's two bounce
states in this case.
Interestingly, however shallow
this potential might be,
however small, z0, the
circle, will always
have one intersection,
so there will always
be at least one solution.
That's the end of that story.
Let me say that for the
odd case, odd solutions,
I will not solve it.
It's a good thing to do
in recitation or as part
of the home work as well.
The answer for the odd case is
that Psi is equal to minus Eta
[? Cot ?] Eta.
And in that case, I'll give
you a little preview of how
the this [? Cot ?] looks.
It looks like this.
And then there are more
branches of this thing.
So for the odd solution,
you have these curves.
And if you have a
circle, sometimes you
don't have a solution.
It doesn't intersect this.
So these odd solutions, you
will see and try to understand,
they don't always exist.
You meet a potential
that is sufficiently deep
to get an odd solution.
And then the odds
and even solutions
will interweave
each other and there
will be a nice
story that you will
explore in a lot of detail.
But the is, you've reviewed
the problem to unit free
calculation, in which you
can get the intuition of when
solutions exist and
and when they don't.
But solving for the
particular numbers
are transcendental
equations, and you
need a computer to solve.